[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where
people where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I am Rachel Cruz
hosting this hour with my great friend
and Ramsey personality Jade warshaw and
we are here to answer your questions
again about your life and your money it
is a free call anywhere in the country
atle
88255 225 all right we're going to go to
the phones this hour and we have is it
deian possibly in Dallas hey welcome to
the
show hi thanks for taking the call
absolutely how can we
help so I'm I'm a new listener I just
came across you guys recently and heard
you given some great advice and hope
that I can get some as well um I I have
a pretty significant student Lo debt
about
230,000 um dollars W what'd you get your
degree
in Business Administration and it's a
master's too so it was two two degrees
but still quite quite a hefty tag and
then I have um basically no savings or
anything so um I'm just trying to
understand how I can maybe chip away at
this and get myself on track I'm I'm 49
so I'm like I I don't know position is
it just you or do you have a family
married I'm married okay and does your
husband have any debt or just this one
student loan you guys have
together no just this one student loan
okay well what do you guys earn
I um I I earn about 170 in base but I
also have like a incentive like a a
annual incentive of
another um 20% so maybe 50 to 60 and
then I do have like these like stock
incentives that I can cash in once a
year what can you get but I sorry what
can what can you get if you cash in the
stock
incentives it just depends on what the
stock is trading at the time but
probably around
20 to 30 what about your
husband um he doesn't work right now
okay and why is that sorry I I'm hitting
you with the questions but I'm trying to
get a clear scope of what's going on
yeah um
just hasn't but he's trying to start his
own business so um I'm just we're
basically a one income family right does
he feel how long has he not been
working uh about two years what what
okay is he feeling the weight of this
debt um I do I don't I know you do
you're
calling it sounds like you guys have
kind of a separate thinking when it
comes to money and debt it kind of
sounds like that from the way you're
talking and I'm just going to be honest
I don't like that this guy hasn't been
working for two years I'm all for
starting a business venture and going
out on your own but I do think that you
have to be making a certain amount you
have to still be contributing
financially while you do that that's the
best way so you're kind of bridging your
way to it as opposed to just stopping
and who I mean you got to make $10
before you make a 100,000 so it's like
if he's not making anything how long is
it going to be until this business
really generates income that's going to
help you guys become debt free you see
what I'm saying when he could go get a
job tomorrow making $50,000 you know
yeah because the truth here is is that
you know with the extra bonuses that you
were saying I mean you could make
$230,000 in a year so here's the here's
what's Wild is what you could think
about if he went and worked and he made
$60,000 that's it you guys could live on
that you could have this paid off in 12
months in 12 but and that's not even
side hustles that we could get into
that's not even cutting lifesty I mean
yeah that would be cutting lifesty just
him contributing yes and so what you
have to realize the bigger picture here
is that you can right if it's just you
working your way out of debt you could
go and lower your uh salary and it would
take you probably three years to pay it
off on yours and that's possible that is
doable but what we want to always give
you is a plan where the fastest most
effective way to get out of debt and the
clear obvious missing piece of this is
that there's not another income yeah and
and again if he's home with the kids and
that's your child care like if there's
reason that's a little different yeah
there there's reasons for for people to
have a one inome household but there's
also people that even have that
situation that choose to go to work to
get it paid off even if they want to be
a stay-at home parent but for you guys I
mean that this is and so to me again the
bigger problem is that you guys aren't
on the same page because if you on the
same page you could knock this out in a
year versus three and a half years and
so I would I would really encourage you
guys if you if you stay on the line I
want to give you guys Financial Peace
University this is our seven our nine
lesson course and if you can
communicate your level of Stress and
Anxiety and fear that you're feeling we
hearing that you know you called us so
we know that it's there and and start to
understand the why it's not this like
well you're not doing that and you're
not it's not a blame game yeah it is a
where you're at where am I at and this
is what I'm feeling and my prayer is in
somewhat of a marriage you know at at
any degree a spouse would look at a
spouse and say my gosh I don't want you
to feel that way 100% what can we do to
do you know to work on that and if and
if he can't come to the table cuz some
people cross their arms and like oh
that's up to you mhm then that's the
then it becomes a marriage problem and
it's not a money problem so you you
start to see these layers of what's
happening but I think it's really
important for you to recognize that
because you can just fix the money thing
you can get out of debt in three years
if you just sacrifice on like the good
news is she's a like even if he never
contributed right there you're going to
be sitting in that average spot where
you pay it off in you know 12 to 24
months and it's going to be gone and
behind you but we want something more
for you yeah and there's something about
you working together to get it gone
because if you just say whatever I'm
going to use my income he doesn't have
to know about it I'm going to pay this
off there's always going to be that
thing between them that's like well I
it's mine and it's yours and this is the
time where you really get to come
together as a couple and I would hate
for them to miss out on that yep so stay
on the line we're going to get you that
and and my my hope would be that you
guys could walk through these lessons
together watch them together start these
conversations because again a plan can
happen so here a say you can pay this
off you have a great salary you could
reduce it not live on as much uh and
tell him sorry but I got to because this
is what we're doing here's our new set
salary for the household and we're going
have to figure it out but if you guys
can work on a team not only does it help
the money situation go so much faster
paying off debt but it helps your
marriage uh which I think you know Jade
this is exactly what you wrote about in
your quick read that's coming out which
is money not a math problem hey got it
right here and there it is yes so you
can actually pre-order it right now you
guys it is brand new it comes out
December 5th which is coming up which is
so exciting so it's only $10 and if you
pre-order they actually get an exclusive
Q&A with you that's right they get Q&A
yes yeah so you can do that um and I and
I love this you guys because it's a
quick read and so for for you all out
there that are like oh my gosh it's kind
of intimidating to dive into all of this
and I don't know where to start this is
honestly the perfect first step because
read it in two hours yes you're going to
you're going to relate to it it's going
to it speaks exactly to the problem that
so many people are having is that
personal finance it's it's 20% head
knowledge it's 80% % Behavior we are the
ones that we have to control and gosh
Jay does a beautiful job walking through
that so go to Ramy solutions.com store
preorder that quick read money's not a
math problem because that's what we talk
about all the time on this show cuz it's
the truth it's a it's a we problem right
it's a me problem it's what you believe
it's what you believe absolutely so make
sure to check that out again ramsy
solutions.com
store
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show we are
taking your calls again it's a free call
anywhere in the country at
88255 225 up next we have Jack in Boston
hey Jack welcome to the show
hey uh thank you guys for having me on
absolutely thanks for calling in how can
we
help so I am a recent college graduate
I'm 22 I just graduated this past May um
and I started working this June when I
you know was originally making plans for
this year as I'm you know entering the
workforce I had taken a job in in the
Boston area um and still had a few of my
college buddies and so there's three of
us and we signed a lease and that's
currently where I am
um after signing the leasee I actually
received a second job offer in which
case I work remotely um I ended up
taking that offer
and um basically I'm I'm calling to ask
you
know because I work remote um I spend
about
$1,200 uh a month in rent then you know
of course there's utilities and a bunch
of stuff just because the area is
expensive how beneficial do you guys
think it would be to move back in with
my parents to help me clear some of my
student loan and car payments H how much
student loan debt is it and how much is
your
car so the student loans are about 27 uh
the car is about 22 and I make 72 and
you make how much
70 72 yeah 72
okay I if it were me I think that you
have a great income starting out I mean
to make 72 starting out at 22 years old
I think is excellent I don't think that
that your rent is especially high it's
not like you're like I'm spending $2,000
a month
um I personally would not move back with
my parents the only question that I was
what I thought you were going towards is
I have these roommates and it's super
loud and I can't get any work done like
I thought you were going to go down that
pathway but it doesn't seem like that's
the issue um I think that you can buckle
down and pay off this debt um your
$22,000 car is is I don't love that but
it's within the threshold so I'm not mad
sure how quickly have you done a budget
do you know how much money you have left
over after rent after groceries after
gas that you could put towards
debt yeah sure so you know each month
after I make all my payments I save
around $ 800 to ,000 already oh good
that's good yeah Jack okay so this is
always kind of a tough question because
mathematically it's like you know you
would think our answer would be like
absolutely whatever you can to reduce
expenses and throw as much of the debt y
y y but what that doesn't factor in by
just kind of like using that escape and
using that plan is that there is
something to be said about that Jack
signed up for the student loan and Jack
signed up for the car loan and so Jack
needs to figure out how to do this and
after you do it there is something about
this dignity as a young adult that
you're like oh yeah I had a problem and
I solved it now could part of that
solution be you move home with your
parents and there's a very strict plan
that you're only going to be there for
12 months and whatever whatever whatever
sure right it's not a I'm not one of
these people that's like never ever do
that but not dire straight but I do lean
towards Jade that there's a part of me
Jack that I'm like I think you're I
think you're a grown man and I think
that you can figure this out I think you
could take a side hustle at night to
bring in some more money um I just was
doing an every dollar webinar yesterday
and we talked about side hustles and
there's so many people that were making
anywhere from $800 to $2,000 a month
doing a side hustle so I think there's
ways to earn extra income and um again
if you had a really diligent plan and it
was again something that you're like
this is I you know there's a a time
frame yeah I know what I'm doing and I'm
going to do it and be done and get out
like you could but I don't know Jack
there's a part of me that I'm like I I
think that like you having your freedom
yeah and not moving back in with Mom and
Dad it just does something to an adult
mind when and I always use this example
it's kind of a stupid one but when you
open up the refrigerator and there's no
milk and you don't have bread and you're
like oh man I have to be an adult and I
have responsibilities and I have to
figure out how to make life work and
there is just that extra safety net when
you move home naturally yeah Mom's going
to go get the milk yeah that that like
you know you're going to be taken care
of which is fine but I think it stunts a
level of this personal responsibility
and and being an adult and if you start
dating and like I don't know just all
this stuff just moving back home look
the dating it's the dating for me Rachel
because I would be thinking the same
thing Jack like if I met you and I'd be
like Jack's great and then I'm like wait
but we're going to your mom's house
there would be just this little piece of
me that I'd be like oh man so for that
reason I this is like shark tank for
that reason alone I'm out but the other
thing I wanted to ask you just about
your money is are you contributing to a
401k through your
work I am yep so my employer matches 4%
so I put 4% to 401k and then another 6%
into a rock Ira Okay so just a piece of
advice and this is the way we' teach
right now you're giving away 10% of your
income and if it were me I would pause
that temporarily while and get that
money back in my hand so I can quickly
pay off this debt by the way even if you
did choose to go to your parents house
and live I would still do that because
the whole point is let's get this debt
wiped up as quickly as possible and then
when your debts gone you'll have so much
more money that you can be investing
another 5% when the time comes to be
investing 15% and I love that way more
for you do you happen to have any sa oh
do do get rid of him and by the way Jack
if you have any savings laying laying
around I would also throw that towards
your debt cuz something tells me Rachel
that he is a guy that might have a
little bit of savings in a little pile
so anything extra Jack yeah just throw
it on this debt and I think that you can
fig I think you can do this I think you
can get out without having to move back
home I understand again the math side of
it so if that's what you choose to do
it's not a completely wrong decision
right but there is something in the Hol
picture of who you are as a whole person
that I think is there's something about
just being on your own and figuring out
that I think is great all right up next
we have Gracie in Salt Lake City hey
Gracie welcome to the
show hi thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we
help I have a little question because my
well okay so sorry I'm kind
of talking in circles here so I'm
wondering if I should get life insurance
for my daughter she's 10 months old um
my mom got life insurance for me when I
was a baby which is awesome but my
husband doesn't have any life insurance
at all and so he's kind of like it
doesn't matter and I'm kind of like well
but it would be nice and um I just want
to hear your on that yeah for sure okay
so a rule of thumb is that your
insurance and your Investments should
always be separate and usually when it
comes to children getting life insurance
there's a level of whole life in there
there's a an investment vehicle within
it and it and ends up being an entire
Financial product that that is is always
it's not a good product essentially
because we what you want to think about
with life insurance is that if someone
is dependent upon your income you want
life insurance so your husband needs
life insurance Gracie you even if you're
a stay-at-home mom need life insurance
but we recommend term life and go down
that path so anything like there's like
Gerber Insurance like uh and again a lot
of whole life yeah a lot of Whole Life
policies will Market to children and
they're like oh yeah if you put this in
and then it's going to grow to this and
I mean it it it's it's this entire
honestly it's the whole product is just
crap because the investment inside is
not great and your your baby doesn't
need life insurance depend upon her the
whole purpose is if something God forbid
was to happen to you or your husband you
want to make sure she's taken care of
cuz right now you guys provide
everything for her so if your baby were
to have life insurance if God forbid
something happened to the baby that's
then you guys would reap the money from
it and that doesn't make sense it makes
sense that if something were to happen
to you or your husband there would be a
ton of money there waiting for her that
whoever her caretaker would be she would
be just fine so it's kind of like
flipping your mind on why do we take
this out and what's it really for yes
and again people will throw in the whole
investment side but again if you open up
a whole life policy and she goes and
tries to C and she cashes it out at 18
or something and and changes it up um
what she could have had if you had just
invested it in a mutual fund under like
an utma account or you even put into a
college fund for her like a 529 would be
Leaps and Bounds more money you would
gain way more of a rate of return and
interest on that versus the crappy
Investments that sit inside of life
insurances so it's a great question
Gracie again she does not need life
insurance you and your husband need life
insurance and term life and we always
recommend Xander insurance so if you go
to Ramsey solutions.com you can find
them on our site um they're the they're
where we get our term life insurance my
husband and I right uh because they have
great rates they shop all different
Services it's not just one provider that
they look at and so life insurance to
all of you listening if someone is
dependent upon your income you need life
[Music]
insurance
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single s
course for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us netw
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
the ramsy show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for home services for over 40 years
neighborly has an exclusive network of
trained local service providers backed
by the neighborly Done Right promise so
if it's not done right neighborly will
make it right visit neighborly docomo to
learn more love it today's question
comes from Amy in Louisiana she says how
do you navigate social social situations
while trying to stick to a budget I
recently volunteered to help with a
friend's baby shower and my husband and
I agreed upon a certain number to spend
on it the girl whose shower it was
connected me to another friend who
wanted to help host who I had never met
in the planning conversation I asked her
what her budget was and told her the
number I could help with she said she
didn't have a budget but my contribution
was fine long story short the shower
ended up being bigger and more expensive
than I expected it's way over my budget
and she asked if I could reimburse her
to pretty uh if I can help reimburse her
to pretty close her half so to close a
like close a gap there's a typo there
this is awkward I feel like it tried to
set expectations but here we are help oh
jeez wow look I almost lost it whilst
reading obviously here's the thing um
you told her from the beginning yeah
Rachel correct me if I'm wrong because
this look this is what Jade would Jade
go go J if I told you from the beginning
I can spend $200 then I am spending $200
and if she who did not have a budget
said that's great thank you know
whatever your contribution is that's
fine if she already said fine then at
that point if she chose to buy other
things I am not reimbursing you matter
of fact I'm going to go like well why
would you spend more like I would be
asking her questions as to why she chose
to spend more when yep she could have
easily just matched my budget and it
been even 200 200 yes I know so Amy I
mean honestly you did such a you were so
wise in it I'm like you knew going in
yeah here's my budget talk to your
husband about it you had a set amount
you communicated that M and the other
person chose to do something different
and that's not your problem that's not
your problem you set expectations so
honestly if it's a girl you've never met
you probably will never see her again um
so I wouldn't worry too much knowing
myself I'm probably more I'm probably
more of a people pleaser so I feel like
I would even find the text thread
hopefully like which and send the
screenshot yeah and just say hey so
sorry my husband and I had we had you
know put this money aside this is all we
could do uh I mentioned that to you
earlier here's you know here's a shot of
our conversation I'm so sorry um let me
know if there's anything else I can do
to help not money related or something
but yeah I mean the Silver Lining is
this is a person she's never met now if
this is like if this is a friend then
that is really awkward but I think but
again I think you have to you have to
stick to your guns and you now if you
had not communicated an expectation and
you show up and it's all then that is
like oh man but on the front end so you
guys everyone listening or watching
right now this is a great lesson that if
you go into an event a social event
which happens all the time whether it's
wedding showers or uh weddings with a
wedding gift uh teacher presents uh a
lot of our classes will pull money
together to get one teacher gift yeah
and you know if if there's any type of
group situation and you have a set
amount of money don't be don't feel any
level of I feel bad that I have a set
amount communicate it and say it out
loud because it's going to give you
peace it's going to give you control and
the more practice you have talking about
money in social situations I think the
easier it becomes it can feel awkward at
first but and I think probably one other
thing and maybe who knows if she did it
or not but like as as the planning
commences just being a reminder remember
I'm only going to be able to spend 200
like so she's suggesting oh it would be
so cool if we did like these little
balloon thingies okay but remember I can
only spend $200 oh but like oh I found
this great little caterer D D D D yes
but remember I can only spend $200 like
as long as you make that like the Mantra
that you're saying over and over then
there's no room for anybody to it's so
funny Jade I'm like you know these just
social scenarios whether it's kid
birthday parties or again showers or I
mean anything that has a level of um a
what's it called like not like a group
funding yeah but like the like what's
like like the Aesthetics you want the
Aesthetics to be beautiful 40th birthday
part you know big celebrations all of
that you know there is this balance of
you want to celebrate people so if
you're putting something on for someone
a good friend you obviously you want to
celebrate that person or if it's you
throwing it for X Y and Z in your family
right you want it to be nice like I get
all of that you want to be beautiful you
want it to be beautiful but also you
guys it's just gotten out of control the
expectations of all these events is
crazy is crazy so it's not normal like
just so you know that it's not normal to
have food trucks at your 2-year-old's
birthday party with bounce house like
it's just that's not normal but it's
become normal so we have this
expectation that this is what our life
should look like to some degree and it's
not I heard plenty of stories about um
like bachelorette parties oh my gosh you
guys are getting married right now I
listen to girls that are getting married
and they're in the bachelorette parties
and the wedding showers and the weddings
and there's a trip if there's a trip
involved oh yeah there always is now I
was like only the Kardashians did that
like when I was getting married 15 years
ago I was like people didn't go on these
like extravagant trips spend you have to
SP you have to Fork over some major cash
to be in a bridal party these days it's
really it's really I wish we all could
just like all the women in America could
lock arms and just make a pack that like
we won't do this to each other like we
will all just together yeah our big
birthday part everything like weit it's
okay it's okay we're not we're not we're
not doing this yeah I'm not doing it
it's hard so so hard but again clearly
verbalizing what you can do is Wise It's
not awkward it's actually very very
smart for you and your money that's
right good job Amy all right next we
have Joey in Manhattan hey Joey welcome
to the show hi good afternoon thank you
so much for taking my call absolutely
how can we
help um yeah so I can explain a little
bit of my situation um but essentially I
am 23 years old I make about $60,000 a
year and I want to save up for a house
and I know that kind of like the
traditional rule is to pay cash for it
um but my parents struggled with debt
you know as I was growing up so I'm a
really big saver and for that reason you
know I try to prioritize um Roth IR you
know different stocks that I have I also
have life insurance which I'm sure uh
you both have some opinions on um but I
guess to boil it down my question is
really how much should I be saving to
buy something because I'm a little bit
against renting even though I know that
that's totally okay if that's still
allows me to save I mean I love that
you're thinking about all of this and
you're trying to make smart choices with
your money I think I would applaud you
on that uh you know you mentioned paying
cash for a house yeah if you have the
patience and the funding to save up and
pay the whole thing full out and cash I
think that's great but um if you don't
want to do that that's also fine you
know I'd look for some some situation
where you're paying at least 20% down
since you really were hoping to go the
cash option um at least 20% down I'd
look for a 15-year fixed conventional
rate mortgage and I'm just if you don't
mind I would just love to poke a few
holes in how you're doing this because I
think you might be able to do this in a
more effective way do you mind
absolutely all right yeah no go ahead so
you mentioned stocks that you had yes
can you tell me a little bit more about
that and how much is there yeah so I
have about 8,000 kind of spread across
um Regular stop stocks that I just
invested on my own via like the Robin
Hood app so different things like apple
Facebook uh Tesla and just like big kind
of like famous stocks that I know kind
of will do well over time yeah in
addition to that I do invest um just
like on the app called acorns I have my
Roth IRA through them so I have another
12,000 just kind of invested in like one
of their aggressive kind of sets so it's
just different stocks that they kind of
pick for me and manage okay what
percentage do you put towards
that it's not a percentage I have well I
don't know what off top of my head I do
normally about a thousand a month
depending on where the my point in
saying all this is you might have a
little bit more to put towards this than
you think I'd probably stop with the
stocks and if you wanted to get here
sooner than later I'd probably put some
of that stock money towards saving for a
house especially if you already have 3
to 6 months saved anything that you save
up past that is really going to help you
get that down payment quickly so if it
were me if I had those 6 months saved
then I would probably liquidate those
stocks put it towards a down payment and
if there was any other cash laying
around above 3 to 6 months I'd use that
to start building that savings for a
deal payment as well yeah any a
non-retirement joey can go towards that
it's great this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with my friend and Ramsey
personality Jade warshaw and
Thanksgiving is coming up you guys and I
wrote a kids book called I'm glad for
what I have and so the idea of gratitude
and contentment and all of that is is so
keute and again it's kind of part of the
the holiday that we are in even this
week so if you have not had a chance to
grab a copy for your little ones or the
little ones in your life I'm glad for
what I have uh learning learning
contentments and learning spoiler alerts
that God's love is the thing that
fulfills you apparently I haven't said
that enough and some of my Amazon
reviews were like it's religious they
didn't tell us and I was like oh gosh
sorry spoiler alert it's God that feels
that feels us and brings deep
contentment but these little these
little animals you know go through uh
understanding that their stuff is not
bad but they start to believe if I can
just have more and more and more I'm
going to be happier and happier and
happier yeah which we can fall into that
mindset as adults too and at the end of
the day we all know that it just doesn't
fulfill us the way we think it does so
I'm glad for what I have my new children
book you can check that out at Ramsey
solutions.com
store love up next we have Ryan in Raley
North Carolina hey Ryan welcome to the
show hey how are you guys thank for
having me absolutely thanks for calling
in how can we
help um so I have a few questions um I
guess I have a pretty decent amount of
money saved um and I was kind of
wondering how to go about making it more
of like a passive income um
and uh just seeing if there's anything
better I could be doing with my money
than what I'm doing now yeah that's a
great question okay so how much money do
you have
saved uh about just a little over
150,000 okay and what's it in now
uh mostly CDs okay and do you have uh do
you have any debt Ryan no no debt and do
you have and any other savings besides
this any
retirement um well that's money that I
just have set aside that I don't touch
at all um so I guess that would be like
towards that yeah okay but you don't do
you have like a Roth IRA or a 401k oh
yes yes yeah yeah and I have a tsp also
cool okay and how much money do you make
a
year um now not too much um I took a pay
cut um I'd say like 50,000 now okay okay
perfect and what's your living situation
are you renting do you own a home where
are you at with
that um I'm in the military now so I
don't have um so I don't own anything
now just military
housing yes okay what branch are you
in uh the Army okay great well thank you
for your service and sacrifice doing
that we we greatly appreciate it so yeah
this is a this is a good amount Ryan I'm
very impressed that you saved
$150,000 you have it in a CD and I think
you're right I think you can put it
somewhere yeah uh that can actually get
you a little bit more make make more I'm
just curious when you said passive
income did you have something in mind
like is there something that you were
thinking of that you wanted to run
by um I mean I've only looked at like
property really but like I like other
than that like nothing really um but I I
don't know like what the best thing to
be doing with that is um I can tell you
what I might
do yeah so I'm assuming you have no
debt yeah no debt and other than like
this is the only savings you have so
what I would if this this is what Jade
would do I would probably set aside what
I think my expenses are for about 6
months and I'd put that separate like in
a high yield savings account and then if
it were me how long do you plan on being
in the military in the way that you're
like hopping
around um I guess it kind of depends on
like how how it goes um I probably my
next goal would be setting aside enough
money that when I'm done with the
military or where I'm more stable where
I could buy a home in
cash okay so I probably invest it like
you said 5 years I'd probably just throw
it in an S&P 500 account and let it sit
and in 5 six years when I'm ready for it
chances are it will have grown and I
would that's or at least use it for a
for a big down payment pay yeah because
Ryan I think I think the first goal
would be you know owning your owning a
home uh is one of the big pieces of your
financial picture and so we want you to
be able to do that and then eventually
own outright so what Jade is saying is
is right that if you can just buy it
with cash outright your primary home
then obviously that's not going to be
passive income like your question but it
starts to get you towards a financial
stability because if you just dream for
a second and think oh my gosh if you put
50% or 75% or 100% down on your home and
even if you took out a small mortgage
and you paid it off yeah then you're
that same ability to save Ryan that you
have now is still probably going to be
there in who you are that that's a part
of you you're natural saver you're
looking for ways to make money you're
looking for ways even asking about
passive income and then from there is
where you can say okay I'm going to put
some away for retirement but also yeah
maybe I do go and and I and I get and I
get a property buy a property in cash
and flip it and maybe resell it and you
can kind of be in that game with cash or
hold on to it and rent it out but all of
those things are secondary to your
primary residence that would be the next
big spot but I'm I'm with Jade I mean a
Vanguard account yeah putting in an
index fund like an S&P 500 it's going to
be better than a CD you'll get a better
rate of return on your money um so
that's that's probably I would do
exactly what Jade said I mean I I lean
towards that and it's not as like sexy
and flashy as passive income like right
but is it really passive but it's
stability like we're like you're setting
yourself up for the future and how did
you tell us how old you were how old are
you I'm 27 27 okay so yeah I mean it's
plenty of time to do all of this and
yeah I mean you could look up in 15
years and have some great cash to get
into the real estate game and do it
without risk with cash and all of that
but I think at this place I think the
next wise step um once all this settles
and again the S&P 500 I mean if you get
some growth you'll pay some taxes on but
you could take it out and use it if you
wanted to right but I would probably
just let it sit there because you don't
have a lot of you know you you may not
have a lot of expenses you have no debts
there's no real reason for major passive
income right now that's right would you
would you agree yeah I agree yeah but um
but again I like where your mind is at
because I think that's more of a
long-term play to be looking into that
realm but I think that it's going to be
sooner for you Ryan than some people
listening because you've set yourself up
really well 100% yeah I mean no debt in
$150,000 so well done well done of next
we have Adam in Pittsburgh hey Adam
welcome to the
show hey you guys thanks for taking my
call absolutely how can we
help um so my wife um is uh employed by
a company that um grants stock to uh all
employees and she's been with that
company for quite a while now and has
we've gained actually quite a bit of
stock and I was unsure what to do with
that um with that stock and has actually
come to the point where we have enough
to pay off the mortgage to our house and
serous if we should if that was a
worthwhile sale to pay down the mortgage
essentially one two three
yes okay yeah for sure Adam I mean the
company stock you know we always I mean
I I think it's a nod to them that's a
great thing but you're stuck into one
stock and Enron is always the name that
comes to my head right and so there's
always always going to be risk even if
it's a you work for and even if it's a
great company you're still not
Diversified so we always do recommend
not to put so much into Company stock so
if you guys have that much I would Adam
I would cash it out pay off your home oh
it's going to feel so great how much is
it how much you guys have
left uh it's about 200 Grand come on
Amazing Adam do you guys have any other
debt but it's a sub it's a sub three%
interest rate and that's the only reason
where I'm I'm waffling on that de
decision because because you know maybe
that is a nice sum for you know
retirement one day but I don't know if
that outweighs you know not having that
mortgage at this point in time but yeah
right I I hear what you're saying but
question yeah no I hear what you're
saying but I also think that you can get
a better rate of return by you guys
putting money away for your retirement
and not dependent upon the Employee
Stock that's right that's right um so I
would put retirement in you and your
wife's control in you know 4 k or a Roth
IRA that's more Diversified in mutual
funds and go that route have your house
paid off and you guys can throw so much
money at retirement and have an
incredible retirement so well done Adam
well done thanks Jay for being a great
co-host thanks to all guys in the booth
for making the show happen thank you
America this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with my great friend Ramsey
personality Jade warshaw and we are
again answering your questions about
your life your money your relationships
your career anything and everything you
give us a call at
5225 all right we're going to go to
Vancouver with Juliano Juliano what a
great name welcome to the show how can
we help
hi there thank you so much for having me
on long time listener first time caller
um I had a question so um we're actually
moving to Indiana in about six months
we're just waiting for my immigration
papers to go through I had the pleasure
of Marrying an American okay so great
well welcome to
America
jul okay so uh so you guys are getting
married you're moving down to
Indiana yeah and uh our so we have a
townhouse in Vancouver and um the market
here has just been crazy we've done very
well just by owning so we're looking to
enter the US with approximately 300,000
us and um I'm looking to try and
purchase a house that's under that limit
in order to be mortgage free we're both
29 wow uh whereas where whereas my
wife's pushing a little bit to maybe
have a little bit nicer of a kitchen or
a slightly bigger property and kind of
go more up to the 350 400 range and have
a small mortgage sure um my my big
concern there obviously I value the the
advice you guys give is to try to be
mortgage free um but I'm about five
months into starting my own business and
uh the idea of being mortgage free gives
me peace of mind knowing that I don't
have to maintain such high monthly debts
so how do I talk to my wife and I guess
compromise or get her to see my my view
yeah how much how much are you guys
going to be bringing in a year do you
know
uh I I I have an opportunity to work for
a bank in the US which would bring in
about a 100,000 but I'm currently trying
to pursue my own business which uh I'm
I'm trying to make the same amounts but
it's it's only been about four months
okay what are you make sorry what are
you making anything from your own
business not yet no um but our product
goes live in about a month or so okay
that's great and what's your wife
make uh my wife's a stay at home mom we
have three lovely children okay so great
um have you guys look have you looked to
see what I'm sure you have kind of what
the market is for around under that
$300,000
Mark yeah like in in my own opinion I'm
I believe I can compromise a little bit
more and for around 250 IT the home size
meets all of our family needs it's
really I guess just the trimmings and
slightly bigger size of properties what
my wife's wanting for the the family
what does 250 get you be specific
uh a four bedroom three B 2,000 foot
home on maybe a 4,000 foot lot okay and
how old like how like fairly old or 15
to 20 years old okay
okay um oh man I don't think I don't
think either of you are wrong I was
going to say I can understand where your
wife is coming from I can and I the the
reason I understand where she's coming
from is cuz you could afford you can
afford easily to do that like if you
have $300,000 in cash taking on a 50 or
$100,000 mortgage is you'll be just fine
yes
and I honestly think that it could be
this is a I'm going to do a little bit
of girl math here I honestly think it
could be a little worth it because if
it's a newer nicer property there may be
less spent in repairs when you first get
in so it's like do you want to pay for
Less headache upfront or do want to pay
less and when you come in it's like all
right we got to switch the carpet all
right we got to do something about this
weird tile in the we're we're going to
want to replace the kitchen cabinets in
two years we're going to we're going to
want to do all these things when it
could be more done on the front end with
a very small mortgage yeah I'm voting
can I place my vote can I put my ballot
in absolutely yes I think I'm voting
team
wife okay this is only because well let
me before I vote team wife do you have
any other
debt uh no no other debt no do you have
any money
saved besides
3 we have 25,000 saved it's not
earmarked for retirement or education
it's just general savings yeah emergency
called emergency F actually yes and and
there is a little bit of debt actually
um it's just the debt that I'm accruing
from starting my business what's that
but we're looking to uh currently about
40,000 oh that's not a little
bit no so the the money we're entering
with the us at 300 I factor in that
we're going to be paying this debt down
as well well what I would do is i' take
some of that i' take 40,000 of the 300K
and pay it off
completely because if you want to talk
about going into your new business
whenever that is sounds like you're
trying to build that bridge now that for
me would provide more stress having debt
on the business would give me more
stress than having $50,000 on a home
because with your home at least it's a
forc savings account every time you make
a payment more goes into the equity
right and more goes onto that principle
but with this debt hanging around I'm
sure there's an interest rate attached
plus there's just the stress of oh my
gosh I've got to make this thing
successful because if not we're left
with this price tag and working from
that place of debt is never what I would
recommend you're going to make
completely different decisions do you
see what I'm saying like that is going
to affect how you run your business more
than you could possibly imagine and
comma I want to make sure that you're
not continuing to add debt as you start
this business
right I I hear you so so to summarize
you're saying pay down the acred debt
and then pay off trans that essentially
pay off and transfer the debt over to a
small mortgage that is manageable
monthly I'm saying take the 300,000 pay
off 40 so now you're left with 260 and
then now this does change a little bit
what size home you get so I can't I
wouldn't necessarily it's not swapping
debt for debt it's not swapping debt
from debt is using yes that cash that
you have from the sale of your home in
Canada to help pay off the business debt
and then I think because of that choice
yeah there's you're taking on what we
had said earlier anywhere from 50 to
100,000 may go down to 50 maybe not you
max out a $50,000 mortgage and that's
what we're going to do and I think that
is going to that's going to give you a
totally different mindset um and and
yeah on the on the business side I mean
I think Jade is right we we talked to so
many small business owners through
entree leadership a department here at
RZ Solutions and help walk with them and
one of the phrases and again we're
pretty countercultural I mean even
talking about taking on a small you know
we understand all that but but moving at
the speed of cash it it changes it
changes who you are it changes how you
go home at night it changes your sleep
it changes the anxiety that you feel
towards a small business when there's
not that risk there you're going to move
slower it's not as fun and as exciting
and people we find especially with
entrepreneurs they have so many ideas
and a lot of them are great and
hopefully they all work but sometimes
they get stuck with a bill with
something that didn't work and they're
having to pay for it for years to come
so just be thoughtful on that so yeah
we're we're like half team wife I'd go
half that that year, 50,000 on a
mortgage and you guys can pay it off
quickly and get a better home uh that
you're not going to have to keep up with
as much I think that's great well thanks
so much for calling in this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your healthare care options
for next year if you feel tied down by
your budget check out Christian
Healthcare Ministries chm is not health
insurance it's a faith-based health cost
sharing Ministry that has helped members
take care of nearly 10 billion dollar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsey personality Jade warshaw and
what's fun about being here at the
Ramsey Solutions headquarters is all the
Ramsey personalities work here you know
we're in and out of meetings we see each
other in the hall and we um were talking
about a video that we saw recently which
we we will show you guys here in a
second but the perfect person to talk
about this was walking by Ken Coleman
yeah I got the bat signal it's very
excited Ken come in here and join us for
this segment because there was a video
that was published was it was it
Bloomberg that
maybe Business Insider do you guys know
I mean it was just
everywhere it was it was a Tik Tok video
of a young girl um we're going to say
jiny MH yeah and she was
struggling with the reality of what
working full-time meant uhoh and how it
felt 9 to five 9 to5 the exhaustion so
let's go ahead and uh Play Play that
video sweet girl I know I'm probably
just being so dramatic and annoying but
this is my first job like my first 9 to5
job after college and I'm in person and
I'm commuting in the city and it takes
me forever to get there there's no way
I'm going to be able to afford living in
the city right now so that's off the
table like if I was able to walk to work
and it it'd be fine but I'm not so it
literally takes me like I leave here
like I get on the train at 7:30 and I
don't get home till like 6:15 earliest
and then like I don't have time to do
anything I don't I want to shower eat my
dinner and go to sleep I don't have time
or energy to cook by dinner either like
I don't have energy to work out like
that's out the window like I'm so upset
oh my God nothing to do with my job at
all but just like the 9 to 5 schedule in
general is crazy being in the office 9
to 5 like if it was remote you get off
at 5: and you're home and everything's
fine but like I'm not home it takes me
long to get home and like like people
that drive to the office like it doesn't
you don't get off at 5: and I know it
could be worse I know I could be working
longer but like I literally get off it's
pitch black like I don't have energ how
do you have friends like how do you have
time to like meet like a guy I don't
know like how do you have time for like
dating like I don't have time for
anything and I'm like so stressed out I
just want to hug
her okay first things first she gets
home around 615 and all she has time for
is eating and showering I want to know
how long of a shower she's taking does
she have that's a long shower that's
like do you have kids no she has no
concept of time I don't have time to
work out see boys what 6:15 what are you
doing wait though wait though Ken cuz I
kind of there were parts of me that kind
of felt what she was saying a little bit
what part because I've always worked
from home I've always run business from
home which means like you get the you
have the ability to tweak your schedule
very easily you don't have to ask
anybody if I say I'm going to start my
day at 9:00 a.m. or if Tuesday I go I
got to take my daughter to daycare I'm
going to start my day at 10:00 a.m. and
then I'm going to come back at 900 p.m.
and make up that hour I can do that but
when you when you have a 9 to5 job it's
like no you're here from 9 to 5 that is
your block so it is a lot less freedom
in that way and when I took this job it
was my first 9 to5 I I felt this shell
shock like I was like oh wow this is a
big block of time I've always blocked my
time in smaller chunks you're very sweet
that you what you're saying is not the
same as what she's saying it's not the
same when she gets home at 6:15 all she
has time for is a shower
maybe a quick microwave meal she
saying shook by the the what she's
really saying is she's weak no no this
is a weak-minded young girl no keman
she's struggling she said I like my job
but if I lived in the city and I could
walk there I'd be fine the whole
meltdown was about her time from 615
until bedtime and she didn't account for
the 4 hours thus this is a young girl
who very kind if you're used to more
hours a meltdown on Tik to it is a
meltdown but if you are used to more
hours in your day that you can spend the
way you choose but she it does feel like
this is her first job though it's it's
her first job she is reacting to like oh
my gosh I just can't like this is
adulthood this is adulthood thank you
adult but let me say this I remember I
remember waking up probably like four
months into work after college okay
coming here and thinking like
oh my gosh like this is my this is my
life this is my life for the next 40
years or however long like every point
up until then there's a transition right
Elementary School to Middle School to
high school there's something new and
and you wake up in this like daunting
adult brain where you think this is okay
this is my life forever and I remember
getting home watching Wheel of Fortune
at 6:30 and at 7:00 I was tired no I
wasn't on Tik Tok crying like I knew
like I have bills to pay like we have to
work we're adults here but I do think it
is get tired I think so too you're tired
please tell me you're tired you get TI
you're tired 100% last night my two
teenage boys were out of the house with
friends Josie our our youngest had a
friend upstairs I was in the living room
watching the football game and
completely snoring in between like wake
so I get it that's not what this video
is about this video is hold on a second
you guys think I'm so mean I'm not
you're you're being Kendy the kend since
when did having Common Sense make you a
kudin then guilty is charged because
this gal is freaking out over the amount
of time she has between getting home
from work and going to bed she may
that's what this is about she is
freaking out but she also could be
learning something about how she's she
could be I'm not saying she is she could
be learning something about how she's
what she's bent towards cuz I do think
some people are more bent towards I can
go to a 95 job I can punch my clock I
can be there from whatever 8 to 4 95
whatever and it doesn't bother me and I
get used to it fine and then other
people are like I need to work for
myself I need to be able to set my
schedule I need to be able to start and
stop she could be like oh my gosh if
this is the world like I can't do it she
could be doing that let me take another
I I can take another angle but but but
even Jade let me say this not against
this girl I'm ready for another angle
but okay but but I'm just saying if you
had to and didn't have a choice you got
to work yeah you wouldn't necessarily
probably be melting down here's an idea
you're saying if she if she had no other
options and this is what she had to
do you you there's a gum like you you
would have to find that inner strength
she doesn't have another option you got
to work yeah right right you got to work
let me let me take another teag okay all
right let me just not be a kogan for a
second all right let me let me put on I
think most of America is probably
agreeing with you we're playing devil
almost always do but anyway here's the
thing let me take the caring dad hat for
a moment okay take the car Dad I
understand sweetheart this is a real
shock to your system all the things that
sister Jade and sister Rachel said they
love you they're your older sister or
sister you would be sister with a uh or
an A only I get it here's the point if
you're struggling like this call your
friend uh listen to a Taylor Swift song
stop uh talk to Mom and dead don't go on
Tik Tok and melt down stop with sheared
every OB cuz let me tell you something I
got some crazy thoughts in my head I
don't want anybody to know I sure as H
double hockey stick I'm not going on Tik
Tok going I'm wildly insecure and I'm
anxious and I'm melting down well let me
just tell you I edited some things out
that were even more personal so that's I
edited some things out that were even
more personal so that was the edited
version that's right you did I have seen
and I know yes so what I'm saying is as
the dad can we stop sharing our Souls on
Tik Tok now that K is very good very we
all deserve a chance to melt down but
for God's sake do it in private with
your with a friend with somebody safe
get with Jesus now we're talking about
this poor girl on a huge show and I
don't I don't I don't mean her any ill
will at all cuz I'd actually go oh I
want to give you a hug I get it life is
hard this does suck either move into the
city later when you could afford it or
let's get a job where we don't have to
commute cuz commuting is a real stress I
I don't want to in any way minimize the
commute but you know look you get home
at 6:15 maybe you don't take a
three-hour
shower I don't know maybe or maybe you
work at at 5 maybe eat on the train
maybe get up at 5:30 work out I I don't
know lots of things there's a way to do
it and I will say this it's a c after
having multiple children sitting here
all of us we probably can adjust more
right it makes you it makes you a chess
they don't know tired having multiple
kids is tired to the Bone can I get an
am in amen there it is amen hallelujah
thank you Jesus this is the Ry
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 sell guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Ramsey person night Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with Ramsey person I Jade
warshaw and we brought our other fellow
Ramsey personality Ken Coleman by big
bro big bro stopped in yes walking
through the brother we waved him in
because we had a reaction video last
segment and we just love Ken and we keep
him why don't you stay one more segment
and help answer a few of these calls
coming in so let's go to Kyle in Mak
Georgia hey Kyle welcome to the
show hey Rachel hey J hey Kim thanks so
much for taking the call to day
absolutely how can we
help so uh just I guess a little
backstory my my wife's a teacher um we
live in one County and she teaches in
another um we're currently uh new to the
the whole baby thing but we're all in we
signed up for Ry plus we've got every
dollar premium we've got everything set
up we're starting our budget um so we're
we're we're we're going hard um but uh
we're we're kind of future thinking and
so we're considering whether to uh when
we get to baby step 4 pay off our
current house
completely uh as we're kind of working
through the four five and six or just
pay off enough as a down payment for a
new house in the county where she
teaches now the reason behind it is
because it's going to cost us about
$2,500 a year per child to send them
across county lines to a school where
she teaches that um so we're kind of
trying to figure out what's what's the
the best option to be more financially
prudent for our family's future okay
yeah it's a great it's a great question
so your wife she's teaching at the
county over and so you're just I want to
clarify make sure I got the question
correct that you guys are trying to
decide okay once we get to Baby Steps
four five and six should we just go
ahead and
move or pay off our house in full in the
county that you're
in correct yeah so we want to yeah
determine whether we want to pay off
here before moving or you just pay off
enough to move um to where we can move
into a house with all the prerequisite
20% down yeah 15E F do all that quick
question what's the benefit of moving
the kids to the new school district just
to be in the same school as Mom or is it
a better school district uh it's a
better school district so we're kind of
on the outskirts of the the town so
Warner Robins is the greater area and
houseon county is the county that it's
in but we're we're literally like a mile
from the border of houseon County so but
we just happen to not be a part of it I
probably would then i' once you get to
Baby Steps four five and six I'd
continue to pay extra towards the
mortgage just like you normally would
because it's still a forced savings
account and when you get ready to move
and you sell your home and you receive
that Equity that would be your down
payment on your next home that's
probably what I would do yeah how much
sorry how much debt do you do you guys
have to pay
off um so we're at about 130,000 and we
make 150 a year okay so how have you
guys mapped out the timeline on when you
think you'll have it paid off yeah so
we're we're currently looking at May of
2026 um I'm actually about to start a
side hustle with a friend of mine doing
web development and software development
oh good for you um and and hopes to kind
of make some extra money to help get
this done quicker okay but that has the
kids in that school for two more years
do you guys want to move sooner than
that well so they're not in school yet
so our youngest or our only child
currently is about to be two and then we
have one on the way who's doing oh okay
so you guys have some time okay that's
great that's that's good so we have yeah
we have the uh Daniel our young our only
child right now will not even start for
at least three years so by the time we
even get to where he starting school we
won't uh we we be done out of out of
consumer de gotcha um but just trying to
figure out you know how much time do we
give ourselves yeah yeah yeah yeah well
I would definitely still be putting
money towards paying off your house just
like Jade said and then when you guys
get to the point that you're like okay
we're going to move for schools you
start looking and then when you sell
your house all that Equity can roll down
into a down payment and you may have to
still take out a small mortgage um
especially if your house isn't paid off
where you guys currently are which it
probably won't be um but yeah that that
that's what I would do just like Jade
said it's kind of a forced yeah savings
you're not losing anything by doing
that you see
that so what yeah what so it so I guess
that that was really our our biggest
thing was is it when we do decide to
move it's going to be is it worth $5,000
a year to make the move and you know get
into a new mortgage versus just paying
the $5,000 a year what's the $5,000 a
year I am I missing to pay for the kids
going out of District I see so here's
the question you already answered one
part one part of this is the school
system's better where your wife teaches
and that's better for the kids
presumably yes you check that box yes
all right so the question is if the
school system that your wife teaches in
that you want to send the kids to was in
the same place your house was would you
be moving
houses uh yeah I mean we would yeah well
so well no if we were me you stay in the
house yeah so which is more important to
you staying in the house that you're in
now that it's paid off or it will be
paid off or uh saving the $5,000 living
in a different house but the kids are in
the district CU I think that becomes the
ultimate question for me I'd pay the
5,000 a year if I really love the house
yeah because now I get the best of both
worlds so what what's important to you
what's the most important the house or
the kids in the school
district got yeah I think for us it'
probably be the house just because we're
the only reason we moved into this house
was just because we had we we used USDA
and didn't have any down and at the time
we know now we know it's not really
smart but so here's the deal that's a
line item for you now M when the kids
are in school the $5,000 that's your
line item and it'll be 2500 at first
right for one kid that's correct be500
years I mean we're all here we're all
parents here Ken you have older kids
than us but also Kyle my kids they're in
public school and I will say one of the
gifts of it that we have found is that
all the kids are zoned for that school
for our elementary school for the middle
school and high school in surrounding
areas so all my kids friends all live in
the neighborhood next to us and all of
it so there's like a community that's
built so I could see you guys when they
enter you know maybe late Elementary
School to be like gosh we want to be
part of this community and at that point
that's another value that want very very
good point to add and so then we do want
to move for that reason so even your
reasons for for you know maybe you're
good to stay in the house you're in till
they're in second grade third grade then
maybe maybe not always maybe you guys
feel like oh my gosh we want to be part
of of that Community because your kids
are in private school so their friends
would be
scattered everywhere can they are but U
they're in private schools close by and
you wouldn't believe how many kids they
went to public school with in elementary
school and middle school and they've
okay so Rachel makes a very good point
very good point on this real quick
question are the neighborhoods better I
know the school system is better makes
me believe that maybe the neighborhoods
are better in this other area is that
true or false oh yeah absolutely all
right so you can look this up Google
this I won't eat up any time on this but
there is actual data out there and it's
why we moved into the neighborhood that
Stacy and I moved into years ago and it
was a bit of a stretch for us we
sacrificed in other areas to be able to
do it uh but there's data out there that
the the nicer the neighborhood the
wealthier the people more successful
people and that ends up really helping
your kids long-term relationships
they're around other successful families
there's something to that it's not a
guarantee it's not a silver bullet don't
read too much into that but there's
something to be said not just from what
Rachel said from a community standpoint
but also the relationships and how it
bodess for their future you they become
good friends with good families uh that
that really helps long term in their
career they've they've mapped this stuff
out so I would think about that as well
absolutely yeah and our and our church
is is on that side of town as well so we
getting closer to everything is really
the goal and that's kind of where where
we're going to be I would go there but
paying the house off like Jade said
still the right play abely you more
options sounds like you're heading in
that direction at some point yeah maybe
if over years Kyle it'll probably be a
longer term decision for you guys
nothing you'll do in the next year or
two but um but yeah I think it's a great
goal to have and again not to keep on
this point but that's how went tonight
were when our daughter started
kindergarten we knew where we were we
had five years to say okay we're we our
goal was to be in this part of the
county all of it and we started saving
and that was our fiveyear goal and we
made it happen which is awesome so again
I think having those goals for your
family Kyle is is huge and all of you
listening and watching that too just be
you think about yourself it's not just
the money piece which is important and
we want to be wise about that but the
holistic view of you and your family
unit too I think is is huge so thanks
for the call Kyle thank you Ken for
joining us yes I'm going to take off
always a pleasure bu things to do Ken
keeping the world afloat we appreciate
by the way by Rachel's new book I'm glad
for what I have and money's not a math
problem by Jade warshaw bye their Booksy
solutions.com go now thanks so kind Ken
we'll be
[Music]
back
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Jade
warshaw give us a call at8 825 5225 it's
a free call anywhere in the country and
I always feel like Jade the uh the week
the week of Thanksgiving obviously
brings a lot of gratitude and also a lot
of shopping that's right Black Friday uh
is a real shopping day and I think it
really can be to your advantage if you
don't get taken you know carried away
with it to find some deals for Christmas
I know I have some Amazon alerts uh that
are going to be hitting um yep for some
gifts so you can take advantage of that
and also if you go to ramsy
solutions.com SL store our Black Friday
sale is going on so we have great gifts
meaningful gifts for your friends and
family as low as $8 there's audio gift
cards for as low as $8 bestselling books
like know yourself know your money uh my
book The and then Dave's book The Total
Money Makeover baby STS millionaires own
your past change your future by Dr John
deloney as low as $10 wow and financial
peace univers is the lowest price of the
year at
$59.99 my wallets are out actually we
have a uh a a color in camel brown black
and champagne that are going on sale
just for this week specifically so so
many people ask about my wallets and if
they go on sale they usually don't but
we're doing it for Black Friday so make
sure to check that out so go to Ramsey
solutions.com SL store and you can pick
up also Jade pre-sale of Jade's new
quick read money's not a math problem so
again lots of stuff going on here at
Ramy Solutions we are here in the
festivities of Black Friday so take
advantage of these deals get some great
meaningful gifts again for your friends
and family ramsy solutions.com
store up next we have Alex in Houston
Texas hey Alex welcome to the show hey
good afternoon how are youall we're
doing great how can we
help all right so um two forms of debt
um unfortunately I do have a um car car
note a um student loan and um here are
the numbers so basically I make a 40 or
excuse me 52 gross which is 417 net um
at the moment I've U Been saving and I
actually have
$118,000 um saved up oh good for you um
yeah I know I've been trying to save
them as much as possible so my question
is okay do
I I know this is kind of a big deal but
like do I knock out the car if I have
179 left um do I knock out the student
loans what do you have on the student
loans basically uh 12,000 okay you know
I would probably go ahead well we teach
the debt snowball where it's your your
lowest amount so honestly Alex I would
go ahead and just knock out the student
loan debt get rid of that and then if
you have your emergency fund of $1,000
or starter emergency fund you're going
to bring that 18 again all the way down
to 1,000 so you'll throw seven you'll
throw 12 at the student loan get it paid
off you'll have 5,000 left which is
awesome which means you'll only have you
know I guess it close to 12 13,000 left
to knock out on the car so I would go
ahead and just get the student loan done
and then start shipping away at the car
next okay so I also have Kelly Blue
booked it and it I could sell and get it
for like I could sell 13 get get get 13
out of it so does that play into it at
all or like you could sell the car for
what uh sorry I could sell the Kelly
Blue booked it and I could sell it for
um
133 13,000 no I wouldn't because you're
still underwater yeah yeah I would keep
the car cuz it's not it's not an extreme
amount um well you're kind of yeah if
you didn't have this 18K saved it would
look a lot different but with that money
yeah you're going to be out of this in
no time to you know cool very
quickly all right so then knock out
student loans and then throw the 5,000
at the car payment and then just have
that 1,000 saved up right that's we all
said exactly yep that's exactly what we
would do that's great Alex I'm really
I'm yeah and just the and what's what I
love about the idea of just the Deb
snowball and working this plan is that
even though you saved 18,000 which is
incredible um you know I don't know if
you had a goal you were saving for but
the idea you know a lot of people are
just like I just know I need to put
savings away and it's kind of this like
nebulous idea and so there's something
about having that more focused goal of
looking at the car and saying you know
what did we what did we say you you have
like 13,000 left on it and to be like
okay 13,000 that's my next goal and
there's like an actual number to it
there's something really motivating
about that Alex and I would encourage
you you know if you can bring in an
extra $1,000 a month in side hustles
$800 heck yeah make work a couple nights
maybe some weekends and just pick up
some for a short period of time you
could throw a lot at that 13,000 and get
it knocked out really quickly so again
this idea of um putting money towards
that by upping some income cutting
expenses uh I think at your rate Alex
you're you're going to do awesome so yep
get I I'd have that student loan paid
off by dinner tonight J oh come on now
get it out all right up next we have
Heidi in Houston Texas hey Heidi welcome
to the
show hi thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we
help yeah so my husband and I recently
started listening to your podcast and we
are looking at our first house and had
some questions um so we're currently got
free and we've been saving for a down
payment and we've been house hunting for
a few years and finally found a house
that we both really love um and we were
actually thinking about putting an offer
on it today um we've been looking at our
budget a lot and talking about it a lot
and the looking at the money that we
would need up front and we had a
question about the recommendation that
you have for the house payment to be
under 25% of your take-home pay
specifically uh we're wondering if you
include taxes and
insurance um within that 25% are just
the principle and interest um and then
kind of tagging off of that also would
you include the 15% that you're of your
household income that you're supposed to
invest in retirement um before you take
the 25% of your take-home pay or would
that be yeah it's great questions Heidi
great questions so so no you would you
would include that 15% you just look at
your entire take-home pay that hits that
hits your account that and that would
include investing right I mean like it
would be that entire number so you would
not exclude 15% and then look at that
amount as your 25% um no you would look
at your entire take-home pay so that is
I guess the good news and then the bad
news is yes we do include taxes and
insurance in that 25% yeah and not to be
I kind of want to add something else to
it have you guys picked a house yet like
do you kind of know this is what we're
thinking
of yeah so we actually um we were
thinking about putting an offer on a
specific house today actually that um
they're um we're pretty confident that
we'd be able to get we were going to
make the offer in a couple hours here
yeah um that's exting yeah we do have a
specific house in mind uh with like a
specific uh price and everything so good
good I always just I I always tell
people the first time Sam and I bought a
house I was shook by really the cost cuz
I was like we've got our down payment
that's it that's all we need and then
Heidi I was like oh wait a minute
there's the down payment and when we had
to put the offer in they were like
what's your earnest money that you're
going to put down and I was like earnest
money what's that and then they were
like then there's closing cost and some
of those you have to pay out of pocket
I'm like closing costs and then there
was the inspection and the uh appraisal
and there all these things that I was
like I I just didn't know and luckily we
had extra money set aside but I always
like to to tell people hey be prepared I
always say when you go to buy a house
come in with a stacked deck and I say
down payment for D earnest money for E
closing cost for C and then the K I say
considered other things such as
inspection all those things appraisals
so just know going in
so I actually have created a very large
sprey and included all of those
things that's
awesome I've included included all of
those things down payment closing costs
prepaid cost inspection go um the rent
to get out of our apartment in the next
few months um moving expenses um my
husband actually has a 401k that we're
trying to um convert to rth from a
previous job and we'd like to do that
this year since we're in a lower income
um tax bracket this year so I've
included that tried to include
everything I can think of but amazing
well done Heidi well done I mean that's
that's incredible I mean that's a
planner right there yes and the
diligence of it I I'm so excited for you
guys I really am I think you you have
your focused you said you're a new
listener but you are doing all the right
things and being so wise with a purchase
like a house cuz it's the largest
purchase and we want it to be a blessing
and not a curse so we're excited for you
Heidi I hope I hope all the numbers work
out and you guys get the house that you
want thanks Jade for being a great
co-host thanks to everyone in the booth
and thank you America for listening this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with good
friend Ramsey personality Jade warshaw
and we here to answer your questions
it's a free call anywh in the country at
88255 225 so first up we got Cheyenne in
Phoenix Arizona hi Cheyenne welcome to
the
show hi oh my gosh thank you so much for
taking my call I'm fan Girling a little
bit right now oh we're so glad you're
here how can we
help um so I just feel super over
overwhelmed with money um I feel kind of
behind in life I'm a registered nurse
I've been one for about a year and a
half and I currently make around $75,000
a year that's not my take home I take
home about 4K a month um and I have
about 90k in debt and I still want to go
back to school to be able to increase my
income so I'm just looking for advice um
and some reassurance on letting go of my
savings that I have okay how much
savings do you
have um right now between everything all
my um Investments and my 403b and just
Savings in general I have about 60,000
okay how much is a non
retirement um I have 40,000 in a high
yield and about 2,000 in just um like
individual Investments okay in just
Investments okay well you're doing
awesome I mean you got $42,000 saved
that's that's excellent that's
impressive very impressive I also wanted
to know if you're I also wanted to know
if you're currently investing
still yes I um for my 403b through work
I have 12% going to my invest or that
account
okay all right so um I know you're
probably not going to like what we have
to say because I know there's a lot of
that security feeling even though you
feel stressed and anxious and
overwhelmed um I think part of that
anxiety is just knowing you have this
$90,000 of debt blooming and the way I
feel like maybe you've combed that is
just to kind of put some savings to the
side to kind of make you feel okay but
yet it's not the problem isn't going
away because the problem isn't lack of
savings the problem is this debt that's
hanging over your head that's preventing
you from moving forward and going to
school it's preventing all of this stuff
and so um you know we always say
Cheyenne around here that if you're not
happy with your current Financial
picture that means you can't keep doing
what you've been doing you have to do
something different and it's going to be
uncomfortable change is not fun and so
looking at money and acting differently
with your money is going to get you a
different result and I would bet because
we have social proof of literally
millions of people that have done this
that there is a different way and not
that what you've done is wrong I mean
you have saved and you've done a really
great job but I think there's a couple
of things that you could change here and
it's going to feel
uncomfortable but I think it's going to
make a big difference in this picture
Cheyenne are you
ready yeah Jade do you want to drop the
ball I feel like I have to drop the
hammer um first things first I would
pause
investing because you were like I make
75,000 and you said it yourself I make
75,000 but I only take home 4K which
means you feel that 12%
leaving each month and you feel it
leaving because you know there's this
debt there right so so I would
temporarily pause the 12% get that money
coming back into your hands and then I
would take that along with my 40,000 in
savings I keep a th000 aside because you
just need a starter emergency fund just
a little cushion there so I'd take
39,000 of it along with the 2K that I
have sitting there so now you've got
41,000 and I'd put it on this $90,000 of
debt and I knock that back now you're
looking at you know a little under 50
and I would then because you've got this
12% back in your back working for you I
would just keep going strong and just
pound this debt until it's gone now my
next question to you is what kind of
time do you have to be working over
time um right now I don't have a whole
lot of time I work the three and 12 hour
shifts a week I work an extra day at a
different job I just added on and I'm
still finishing my master and J in
January but I have clinical rotations on
a different day and online school
another day so you've kind of you've
kind of hit your max at time yeah and
look I look I I get it there are times
where you get to this equation and
you're like all right I'm putting as
much time and effort as I can and when
it gets to that you've just got to ride
that horse across the finish line and
know okay this is the margin I have and
I've just at that point I'm just locked
into my timeline and I know I've done
the math at this point on this date I
will be debt free and so if you don't
have every dollar um Austin will pick up
and make sure you get every dollar
because I want to make sure you plug
these numbers in because with every
dollar you can literally go in and say
okay here's the numbers I'm working with
if I do this certain amount by this
specific date I will be debt free and
then by this specific date I will be
able to build back up my savings and
then by this spefic do you see what I'm
saying yeah cheyen when are you done
with you said you have um you're still
doing your Masters when are you done
with school yeah I'm done um mid January
so after that I'll be able to pick up
like two extra shifts which will help a
lot perfect and that extra job that
you're taking that that you have did you
do I'm sure you did a price comparison
versus just working overtime with your
full-time job versus this new do you get
paid more yeah I get paid more perfect
awesome awesome well done so great yeah
I have a follow question yeah sure um
for the pausing of Investments should I
still keep the match at 4% I would not I
would because here's the thing you're
going to be out be out of debt very
quickly if you do the prescription that
we just wrote you you're going to be out
of debt uh let's see that leaves you
with 48 left uh could you live on half
of your
income yeah okay then you're out of debt
in a year a year and a couple of months
maximum and then when you're out of debt
you're going to build back up your
savings uh whatever you think is you
know four to uh 3 to six months yeah
with within that area you're going to
build that back up and then you're going
to be able to invest 15% and then at
that point cheyen is when I would start
saving up some other cash if you want to
go back to school and here's the wild
thing I feel like sometimes and it's not
always the case but sometimes we do find
that people are like okay I want to go
back to school this this and this and a
lot of people just make the decision
today regardless of the money and they
go into debt and they do it versus
having a little Pat a little bit of
patience and you may look up Cheyenne
I'm not saying this is the case you
could look up been a year from now start
saving and actually like you know what I
have no debt I'm funding my retirement I
have Savings in the bank you're going to
be in a completely different place
emotionally with money at that point and
you may say I think I'm good I think I'm
going to work towards a you know paying
off my house or a down payment I'm going
to keep moving on with my financial
goals cuz career-wise I feel settled and
set now you may not you may say hey I'm
going to spend another year saving to
pay my way through school which is great
too but but you never know but that's
that's the beauty of saving and that
delayed gratification is your is your
choices change your options change and
your desires change and so you actually
let time do its work versus making an
instant decision going into debt and
you're stuck in this path so that's one
reason we love the idea of saving up and
paying for things cuz it puts some like
breathing room into the equation thanks
for calling Cheyenne this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
yeah
[Music]
some of the comments on YouTube Jade
always kind of make me laugh with all
the Dynamics of the Ramsey personalities
cuz sometimes like I don't think Rachel
and Ken really get along or delone seems
to not like Jade or like there's all
these like these funny like people
predict our relationship but I can tell
you in good faith everyone we genuinely
enjoy each other all of us we're going
to have a Christmas party with just us
and our spouse is coming up at Jade's
house like we are having fun that's
right so we love the people we work with
and you know who we love is sweet George
camel yes we love George camel and if
you know him you love him he actually
co-hosts smart money happy hour with
George and you guys he has a brand new
book coming out in January called
Breaking Free from broke so you can
pre-order today for only $20 you get a
hundred $100 of free items okay so this
is instant access to George's newest
talk show me the money you can exclusive
access to an online preview private
event and Q&A with George the ebook the
audio book there is so much there and it
even includes three months of every
dollar premium I don't think I realized
that excellent okay that's worth even
just pre-ordering to get the every
premium that's amazing so George does
such a great job I mean if you listen to
him him here on Smart money happy hour
or the Ramsey show you know that he
brings humor he brings facts and the way
he looks at money has it it's such a
great thing cuz he exposes so many there
he is he's out the lobby George there he
is he's like yes that is all true his
parents we met them earlier in the break
or we've known them we've we got to see
them down from Boston uh so all that to
say go to ramsy solutions.com store and
pre-order George camel's new book
Breaking Free from broke we love you
George Happy Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving all right let's go to the
phones let's go to Cole in Memphis
Tennessee hey Cole welcome to the
show hey thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we
help yeah so I'm 22 years old I'm active
ding in the military right now so I make
about 60,000 a year um and I'm in a
position where I don't have a lot of
expenses so after like all my bills and
food I just have like 2,000 every month
to awesome to send whatever I need um
but I do have $23,000 in student loans
um right now I have about 4,000 saved up
because I'm I been setting like 1,700 a
month towards them okay um but now I'm
kind of in a situation where I I have an
unreliable car like the AC doesn't work
in Mississippi and the engine's kind of
not working well I've had to repair it
and I I want to get one by spring when
it starts to get hot get a new car I'm
not driving around with no AC yeah um
but I want someone reliable and
obviously I don't have enough saved up
to buy like a new car cash but I don't
want to you know go with another junker
so I'm just not really sure how to
allocate that 2,000 to saving for a car
and soon loans and then if I should buy
a new or used car okay yeah if you were
to Kelly Blue Book your car right now do
you have any idea what you could get for
it yeah I think it was like 1,200 1,200
okay perfect yeah um okay so we always
talk about Cole your four walls that you
want to make sure are covered which is
food shelter utilities and
transportation and in that
transportation is a reliable car now um
yeah the AC doesn't work I understand
that and and then Tennessee Heat come
June you don't want that I totally
understand that totally understand that
so what I would do is I would put some
money aside if you're a you're able to
save six you're able to save $2,000 a
month you said after expenses and
everything which is which is incredible
and so I mean I would shoot to try to
have
maybe I don't know Jade six grand saved
at least yeah uh six to eight grand
saved and so that's going to take you
you know three four months to be able to
save that um and so that gets you
into what is that um March April which
with weatherwise is still yeah cuz I
mean he's already got the 4K saved yes
so oh yeah that's right that's right so
I I'm trying to do two things at once
here which I know we don't always
recommend but knowing that you're going
to have to replace your car it is it's a
needed expense so you want to be able to
save for that but I also want you to
start chipping away at the student loan
at the same time or what you could do
you could go that route or you could say
okay I've got $4,000 saved um next month
when I get paid in December I'll have a
new another $2,000 to put with that and
what if you just and then plus the money
from selling the car so that's six 7
7,200 so what if you said okay I'm going
to keep a th000 out as my starter
emergency fund and then I'm going to
just take
$6,200 I'm going to get a new car and
knowing that in January that starts my
baby step two debt snowball payment and
as soon as I'm done paying off my debt
if I'd like to put a little bit more to
upgrade you can do
that because you said you like start
like so you say get a new car like get
like pay cash for a used one or actually
get a new one no in December I would
take in December when you get your next
paycheck because you said oh I have
2,000 left every check and margin so in
December when you get paid I take your
2,000 of margin I'd add it to your 4,000
that you have saved then I'd sell the
car that you have I'd get about 1,000
bucks for it like you said and so what
does that leave you with 45 $7,000 and
then I'd keep aside 1,000 just as a
safety net and I'd buy myself a $6,000
car now I heard you earlier when you
said I don't want to buy another junker
and I get that this is very temporary I
just want you in a situation where
you're driving something the engine's
not crazy there's ER I mean yeah the
basics and then you're going to take in
starting in January where you're like
okay now starts my student loan payment
deal and I'm going to put 2,000 and I'm
going to be done with it by the end of
the year so this time next December
you're going to be like all right I'm
done I can start upgrading my car if I'd
like to or if I if this car is still
doing well for me I'll start building up
my emergency fund so you've got options
yeah and Cole I mean with this math
right now you could be you could have a
new Su or a new new use New To You car
in January your student loan paid off by
this time next year um and I think that
when you you kind of start gaining that
traction you may find yourself being
like Oh my gosh okay a few nights a week
I'm going to work extra and try to get
even that paid off by October of this
year right even shaving a month or two
off of your timeline and your car let
that be kind of the motivator to be like
I want to get rid of the student loan
debt so I can save some more cash and
the great thing about a $6,000 car is it
really doesn't go that much further down
in value and so it hits gone yeah yeah
yeah you're pretty much at the bottom of
it which is great uh and you can keep
stepping up in car that way so that that
is for sure what we recommend do not go
get a brand new car with a car loan this
is the this is the slower process and
way Cole but this is going to give you a
lot more freedom a lot less stress when
you do things with cash so thanks so
much for your service Cole uh we really
appreciate you uh yeah so Jade you
mentioned um earlier and I think even
Cole's situation you know it it is
amazing to me when you can be
intentional with with every single
dollar and I love that Cole cuz this
doesn't always happen with people where
he's like I just happen to have $2,000 a
month like he doesn't have a lot of
expenses which is such a gift and you
want to take advantage of that um but
but having purpose for your money that's
one reason we'd love every dollar our
budgeting app um and being so specific
you guys the budgeting that idea I love
it Jade know you love it this is
something that you and I we we fond over
because there is a a foundational
principle you guys with your money is
that you have to be intentional so
whether you're living paycheck to
paycheck or whether you're in Coal
situation you got two Grands every month
that you just happen to have that stuff
just kind of just you either stay in the
cycle of paycheck to paycheck or that
2,000 if you're not intentional with it
it starts to dwindle away and so being
so specific with every single dollar
that you have is so key to winning and
all of you that are new listening to the
show or watching the show this is a
crucial crucial part of your financial
picture is budgeting so if you have not
downloaded every dollar download every
up upgrade even to the premium version
because it connects to your bank there's
paycheck planning there's so so many
other features but getting this Rhythm
don't you agree I think and even going
into the holidays with with um shopping
and everything you guys this is the way
to get control of your money is to
budget I definitely think and I I tell
people all the time we have the free
version of every dollar which if you're
if you love handson and you love really
having your hands in every piece of it
then free version is great for you but
the premium to me it has these two key
factors that so many many people miss
when it comes to budgeting they're like
Jade I'm doing a budget why is it still
not working I'm like you're probably not
planning your paychecks so you know
exactly when to spend the money that
you've budgeted for and the premium
version does that and there's that
automatic transaction tracking that is
critical you must track your
transactions each day otherwise you're
not going to win with your budget and so
every dollar premium provides that and
that is the key that's what you need yep
so download the app or go to Every
dollar.com and get started you guys we
want you guys to win and be intentional
so whether you're coal with $2,000 a
month or you're living paycheck to
paycheck a budget is something that is
going to help you it is a tool and a
habit that's going to
[Music]
[Applause]
help
[Music]
well standing over on the debt free
stage this is one of our favorite types
of calls Jay that we get to do is talk
to people on the debt free screen stage
and we have Edwin and Carla
here with us hey you guys hi hello hello
okay so obviously you're here standing
on that stage for one reason you're debt
free yes oh amazing okay where you where
are you guys from uh we're from Los
Angeles okay so la all right so how much
debt have you guys paid off
$139,000 wow oh my gosh and how much
time 36 months 36 months making making
what kind of income
we started off at
$131,200
together no side gigs and um soon we're
looking at a 34,000 between uh raise
between the two of us W oh my gosh so
well over 200,000 you guys what do you
guys do uh we're um School social
workers so we do mental health in the
school settings I'm new to it uh I just
recently got my grad school degree
actually during those 36 months we cash
flowed my University wow oh my gosh you
guys incredible what what incredible
work that you do and incredible that you
guys paid off this amount amount of debt
so
$139,000 so what all what kind of debt
was
it uh we were pretty
normal um personal loans um title
loans uh payday loans car loans leases
fases um did it all all everything did
it all okay so what happened student
loans sorry wow yes so what happened 36
months ago that made you say what are we
doing
well well uh yeah we had a mess so much
dead and uh at that time uh we had to
move back in with my parents and uh we
were married and moving back in with my
parents and we were like okay well
something's got to give enough is enough
and actually it was during college I met
a a classmate of mine her husband is a
pastor and they actually uh hosted a s
uh FPU so shout out to uh Rudy Rodriguez
of New City Church Pastor Rudy and his
wife Christine um so we got started with
FPU we did the uh what do you call it
the
plasectomy plastic surgery C up those
credit cards oh look at that and then we
just uh opened up about uh finances
because I think uh that's something
that's really important in a marriage
right A lot of people don't have shared
finances we've been uh learning little
by little that's right and uh yeah we
just uh opened up and then we started
budgeting and we just followed uh Bab
step one got that $1,000 and then we
went crazy with baby step 2 oh go so
inquiring minds want to know what was it
like when you because you say we opened
up we open what was it like when you
opened up and started combining your
finances like be real it was actually it
wasn't too bad it was about me getting
over the guilt and shame I actually when
we first started dating I kind of kept
it from him cuz I brought the bulk of
the debt into the the marriage and I
just uhhuh there was a lot of Shame and
guilt I made a lot of poor decisions and
he's amazing and he was very supportive
and I eventually opened up and he's like
oh don't worry babe like I got you like
we're going to do this together so um
that really helped us to catapult
into um paying this off we uh we really
combined incomes once we got married
pre-marriage counseling and our marriage
Retreat helped and yes the vows like
just really adhering to those really
helped us so wow now we're plus I saw
the potential in my wife she was great
since before I even we even started
going out she was just great and I was
like you know what that's that's my
person we going to do this that's what
I'm talking about wow so great cuz you
guys I mean
$139,000 is no joke like we're not
talking about $30,000 of debth $1
139,000 so what all did you do cuz you
said you guys are you guys work um with
mental health in the school district but
you must have picked up some side
hustles and all of it so tell us your
workload cuz I know it was a lot oh yeah
um Uber Eats Postmates tutoring front
desk support night shifts you name it
right I even did a desktop support on
the side so uh before I started mental
health cuz um I just recently started
like like this year uh I used to do a
desktop support for um Aerospace company
but then on the side I would do like
helping my friend set up his
DJ anything yes so how many hours would
you say at the most because we talk to
people when we say hey do some side
hustles and all this and some people are
like oh gosh gosh you guys are the prime
example of going big or going home so
how what like at the highest point how
many hours were you
working probably
about right under 70 probably between 65
and
yes each see this this right here this
is what it takes to get to your
shirt straight out of baby step and
again we're not saying to work 70 hours
a week for your life that's not
sustainable but for a season and it
probably wasn't even that for 36 months
right but at the peak that was that was
the most that was the most oh my gosh
you guys you're incredible I got to know
cuz my husband and I we did this the
side hustle thing and there's always one
that you hate right there's the one that
you're like all right I got to go do it
what was the one that you were like I
when I let this one go I am free I got
this one this is a this was a front desk
support and it was a Friday Saturday
Sunday I left my um 9 to5 my salary job
and I would be miserable I hated it but
I knew we we had to do it in order to to
move forward wow I remember I used to
take her and pick her up every night oh
my gosh just I was so sleeping so
amazing you guys but you're here you hit
the Finish Line how does it feel how
does it feel to be completely de
free amazing I mean we can uh pay for a
Nashville trip and not have to worry
about it yes yes um
I just it's just free it's so peaceful
and um such an accomplishment it is yeah
it like feels like you're being choked
constantly now you can breathe again yes
so good you guys so what would you say
the key to getting out of debt
is uh definitely a lot of love and
communication and
um empathy and understanding yeah so
good you guys know if you have anything
no I agree communication is key working
together as a married couple kind of
like what you were pointing out earlier
it is it is so crucial yeah so important
so crucial you guys you're incredible
I'm proud of you absolutely amazing you
are the prime example of what it looks
like to sacrifice to come up against
numbers like this
$139,000 and paying it off in 36 months
absolutely incredible so Edwin and Carla
well done we're going to give you the
live and give bundle to be able to take
some of that home with you you can give
some away and we are so excited to
celebrate with you so we have Edwin and
Carla from Los Angeles who paid off
$139,000 36 months making 131,000 to 127
during this journey count it down let's
hear your debt free
Scream 1
2 3 we de
free
amazing that's amazing they took their
time with it you can see the relief see
the relief how incredible so good I mean
that's it Jade and and and that's where
I'm just like you can't I know people
have you know different stories
different life circumstances but at the
end of the day if you choose to do it
and for 36 months you and Sam are proof
of that Edwin and car are pro car are
absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible we are cheering them on and
we're cheering all of you on if you're
listening or watching this and you think
I don't I don't know if I can do that
you can look at them as example to say
it's possible we see it every day it is
possible this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Psalm
8611 teach me your way Lord that I may
rely on your faithfulness give me an
undivided heart that I may fear your
name Serena Williams said I am lucky
that whatever fear I have inside of me
my desire to win is always stronger
that's winning that's so good oh my gosh
cuz that fear is real I mean in all of
it there's the fear of change of doing
something new whatever is in front of
you thinking oh my gosh is this possible
but that desire to win it's stronger
love it love it love it all right next
up we have Joanne in New Jersey hi
Joanne welcome to the
show Hi how are you doing well how can
we
help well um we're my my family and I
are facing a serious issue uh my husband
owns a commercial uh a business a small
business with trucks and and um we're
we're actually um facing repossession
and right now our income is not bringing
enough in to cover the cost of our P du
balance okay um right now I'm in school
he um right now we were depending on the
income for the business as well as my
part-time so I just wanted to know like
what options do we have you said trucks
is there multiple trucks like what kind
of business is it no it's actually one
truck it's a commercial truck okay so
he's like a truck semi truck semi truck
okay and you said there's a p do balance
what is the
balance um the P do balance is about
16,000
and I'm just trying to get to the root
of the problem what has caused what has
caused it to get to that point is it
he's just not getting the work in order
to bring in the money or is that he's
bringing in the money but we've got all
these bills and this is just keeps
getting pushed to the back of the line
can you kind of lay out what's been
going
on sure um well uh he he did suffer an
injury um in the beginning of the year
which caused him he was unable to drive
um even when we did hire It Whatever
happened we we lost a lot of our like we
lost employees um where they were not
able to I guess keep up um so the truck
has been sitting around for a little bit
too
so that's another issue why we why we
did become behind we actually had a job
where um we did not get paid for that um
for that job which kind of set us back
too okay so how long has it been where
it's like basically there's not money
coming in he's not able to do the jobs
you're in school how long has that been
I believe six months okay and that's
just an estimate okay so right now you
guys are in crisis mode because it's
kind of like I it feels like you guys
were like something's going to give here
something's going to give here and it
never did and so now you guys you guys
have got to do some serious something
serious here so the truck is $16,000
behind what what have they said like
when is the deadline of hey we're coming
to get this thing
um I believe at the end of the month
they'll probably come take the truck so
how much you guys owe on it
Joanne the full balance I believe it's
about 78,000
okay
um and and coming up with yeah this
amount of money I'm is there because I
mean whatever we can do for it not to be
repossessed because then you just start
from you're starting from scratch yeah
from scratch have you looked into
selling
it um we've tried selling it um but
again
that's that's um the options are very
limited either you know you don't have
any bu any any interest or um we haven't
had any luck with selling it so no h how
what have you got what has been your
attempt to sell
it um my husband actually have may have
more details than I to I know i' I've
picked up some information from him but
I think he he's act family friends um I
think he's actually gone to several
businesses and offered um to sell but no
buyers what is the amount that you guys
are trying to sell it
for um believe the same amount that that
is like the full balance is which is
about 78,000 or what it's whatever it's
worth okay I here's what I would do
um and you have no money sitting around
nothing you can sell nothing you can
like do you have two two other
vehicles uh just our personal vehicles
one which I get to work and to to school
or my regular activities and for him the
same okay and what are those what are
both of those
worth I'm just trying to get your
numbers I would
say maybe 10,000 a
piece only two
vehicles and here's here's what I was
getting at I was getting at a situation
where maybe you get rid of one of the
cars and use that to keep the truck in
operation and then over the next few
months you save up cash and buy another
little beater that one of you drives
that's an option that you could look
into um how old are these cars that you
have one is a 2016 and the other one is
a
2003 okay so maybe it's keeping the 2016
and trying to do something like that or
maybe you have to ask yourself how
desperate you want to get to save this
truck because part of me is like you
haven't been making any money on it for
6 to eight months and part of me wonders
if it's the right business for you and
honestly I hate repos because it's going
to jack your credit it's going to it's
almost like a bankruptcy it's going to
just throw an atom bomb on everything
right but at the same time time I do
think that you get to this point where
it's a necessary ending and you have to
be like look this has not been
profitable this has not been fruitful
for us for many reasons that you listed
earlier and there's part of me go ahead
what I was going to say my aggression to
sell it I mean I feel like that's going
to be the the best and so and it's not
just friends and family Joan I mean like
this is calling companies this is a
cross country that you'll drive it to a
different state to I mean like again it
it is putting the the work and the sweat
and the tears into getting this thing
sold I think is it's going to that's
really the only big thing cuz I mean
even with these cars Jade but if they
can drop the price if they can sell one
of their cars and drop the price by
10,000 like sell it at a deal yes and
you guys are taking the hit I would be
trying to make that dog hunt until the
day they pry it from my fingers right
exact exactly so that to me that's the
game plan is what can I sell to put with
this so that I can sell this get this
car this truck sold a premium at
$68,000 take the 10,000 of your primary
car just to cover all the all of that
and then you start working to pay off
that 16,000 that's so work to get a new
car and you guys just start over versus
this asset just being completely taken
away and like what Jade said it takes
such a ding on your credit so yeah
Joanne if I were you guys um and see
even if you if they can hold off the
repossession to the end of the year uh
if they can give you more time that that
is going to be the thing and again the
urgency that hasn't may have been there
um I don't want to put words in your
mouth but to Jade's point of it being 6
to 8 months that lack of urgency it it's
it's caught up to you it's caught up to
you guys and so there needs to be these
extreme things that happen and again
that is that is finding that's finding a
buyer that that would be my number one
goal and yes and even for you guys
Joanne I mean I there there's even a
point that man I you may want to think
about for yourself pausing school I
agree for where you are and getting a
job and just getting you guys in a place
where money is not just like sucking the
wind out of you we just had a debt-free
scream on the stage earlier and and he
said it he said it felt like it a chug
hold around me and and Joan I feel like
that that's where you guys are it's like
it just feels like the world just keeps
is against you and man and it's like
decision after decision nothing is going
right and you need things to start going
right but that means there's going to
have to be change in your life for that
to happen and it may be uncomfortable to
do things like pausing school to get a
job but getting the money the cash flow
in find a seller for this I think
there's a couple of big changes that
really are possible I mean I don't think
that this is an impossible scenario uh
but it's going to take a lot of work and
some creativity too to to be able to
navigate it's going to yeah but yeah you
can't get past the discomfort like it's
uncomfortable that they're in this
situation but I'd rather be I'd rather
make myself uncomfortable in other ways
to get out of it that are going to be
more fruitful for sure yep we're glad
you called Joanne thank you so much well
thank you Jade for another great hour
thanks to everyone in the Booth to make
this show happen and thank you America
and remember to take control of your
money and create a life you
[Music]
love a